hey leute was geht herzlich willkommen
zu diesem video ich kann es selbst noch
nicht so richtig glauben denn im place
tor ist nämlich jetzt das neue harry
potter research unit herausgekommen
das ist ein spiel das in harry potter
universum stattfindet und das einfach
krass fiel seitlich deshalb werde ich
soll ich heute mal ein bisschen zeigen
aber ich dachte mir schon ein bisschen
langweilig wenn ich das einfach so mache
deshalb werde ich heute einen tag lang
wie harry potter in harry potter
universum leben ich werde mich
ausschließlich mit harry potter
beschäftigen und ein paar typische dinge
machen die man halt in der zauberer welt
machen was macht man in der zauberwelt
nun mal als erstes natürlich man startet
harry potter wird selbst fühlt sich auch
so an dieses spiel zu spielen weil alles
hatten mit harry potter zu tun und wie
ihr vielleicht wisst bin ich ein
bisschen harry potter begeistert ich
werde zu sehr ins detail gehen wir sind
ja auf jeden fall auf der karte und ihr
seht schon um mich herum denn jede menge
verschiedene sachen die man einfach
aufheben kann zum beispiel gm blut und
diese sachen kann man unter anderem
dafür benutzten zaubertränke zu brauchen
weil das spiel ist wirklich mega
vielseitig wir gehen einfach mal hier
auf mein profil ich habe ja schon ein
wunderschönes foto oben in der ecke wie
möglich angelegt ja mein name ist max
krank dass man mit fehlern aus wals
damit hätte ich nämlich in zwei
bereichen ist die welt wieder in ordnung
zu bringen nämlich ein bisschen denn
chaos geraten ist es gibt viele frächter
die bewachen sachen die von ihrem ort
entfällt wurden und die müssen wir
mittels zaubersprüchen besiegen und so
die sachen wieder zurückführen
die zaubersprüche macht man indem man
diese bewegung möglichst schnell und
genau nachzeichnet da habe ich ganz okay
da ist großartig
reicht es wieder standen da kann ich
jetzt einfach nur sauer sein einsetzen
das steigere meine chancen bis hin zu da
seht ihr das ganz genau so funktioniert
das ganze jetzt habe ich die karten des
betreibers wieder zurückgeholt und kann
sie jetzt platzieren und das so die
grobe funktionsweise man muss sich herum
bewegen kann super viel entdecken und
dann wirklich eine ganze welt von sachen
die man entdecken kann ich freue mich
richtig darauf aus zu erkunden und das
krasseste ist ich werde einfach zusammen
mit emrah zu einem harry potter rational
event nach amerika ich hab ich schon
super lange rede lasst uns einfach
anfangen mit meinem tag in der harry
potter bett
frühstück ihr wisst ja ich liebe meine
kaffeemaschine aber heute kann ich
ausnahmsweise mal keinen kaffee trinken
weil es wird eigentlich immer tee
getrunken in der harry potter welt
deshalb heißt es auch für mich gibt es
häuser tetens nicht ganz leicht aber
einen tag der nicht schaffen vielleicht
doch gar nicht so schlecht weil
irgendwie die ganze zeit am husten bin
aber naja für mich okay leute damit
würde ich sagen kann meinen tag im harry
potter universum stab und ich hab auch
schon etwas überlegt was ich heute
morgen machen kann und zwar habe ich
einen original buch die märchen von
beedle dem barden das ist quasi so etwas
wie die brüder grimm und da werde ich
jetzt erstmal ein bisschen drin lesen
von hier stammt auch das märchen der
drei brüder das ist ja wahrscheinlich so
dass bekannt ist der harry potter merck
sind die filme und bücher gesehen hat
dann wisst ihr bestimmt auch warum diese
echt mega interessant ist nur so zu
lesen
okay leute der tee ist ja ich habe auch
ein bisschen ring gelesen und ich viel
mehr gehabt denn ich warte auf dem paket
da sind nämlich ein paar sachen die ich
brauche für mein usa-aufenthalt aber ich
will nicht so viel sagen sondern ich
pack's einfach aus und zeigt euch was
drin ist bot das konto nicht abwarten
ich habe das paket schon geöffnet wir
haben hier alles für meine reise nach
amerika einfach zunächst den zauberstab
von albus dumbledore also den elger
starb daily und original rückblick und
dann haben wir hier für mich einfach mal
den havel fahrschul umhang hilft das
havelpark wappen kapuze richtig schwer
das ding also lieber gute qualität und
dazu noch die schale nach paar leute ich
bin sowas von resi für den trip ich das
jetzt mal alles an bis gleich buchen so
sieht das an mir aus passt nicht so
richtig wenn man eine kamera eine hand
und dabei so ein outfit aber glaube vor
allem die schuhe sind perfekt und ich
will jetzt bereit für den trip nach
amerika
dieser verzichtet bonewitz das richtig
heftig das einfach so ein film replik
essen aber genauso aussieht genauso wie
die anderen sachen okay leute sind jetzt
unterwegs sind in street kann natürlich
trotzdem trifft also fest irgendwas
passiert ihr wirklichkeit aber wir
schauen jetzt einfach mal waffen zu
begegnet wenn wir unterwegs sind auch
den sprachen und ihr könnt hier sehen
auf der minimap sich der hier ist gerade
der adler bayern wenn man nach guten
start ist hier natürlich auch im
reallife der hier vorne gibt es etwas
für uns zu holen das denkmal den habe
ich schon ungefähr 1000 mal geholt
ein gnom bewacht als grundrechte
einzigartig und jetzt die sie beim
ersten mal als natürlich klappt wir
haben ja so ein mega groß raus nach
vorne blickt mal drauf ok ich hab' das
geschenk leute ich habe es wirklich
versucht aber ich muss dir so den preis
nicht ob sie im aufnahmen und dann zu
verteidigen
ich hab nichts nächsten angriff fand
kurz darauf zweimal an
aber es ist mein erstes geld
[Musik]
und ich das ding
wenn man erster gegner für sie kann live
was jetzt im komm ran das waren meine
ersten gehversuche mit dem spiel ich
werde auf jeden fall bevor es nach
amerika geht noch ein bisschen zocken
dort gibt es ein special event im spiel
gleich kommen auf jeden fall kelly maike
und emrah und sebastian und wir werden
zusammen harry potter short aber davor
habe ich mir noch was überlegt ist mein
leben ja ein tag in der harry potter
welt
wir müssen natürlich auch sachen essen
der im recht sind dementsprechend werde
ich jetzt kürbissen pasteten backen
kürbisfest hält ist glaube ich so dass
most iconic harry potter mir keine
andere im ersten buch als die im zug
sind kriegen wir natürlich kürbis passt
hinten und irgendwie an dieses gefühl
ich habe auch kelly geschrieben ist
zeigt sich jetzt mal hier im alltag
erlebt was wolltest du schon immer mal
von harry potter 7 kürbis pasteten und
zwar bei mir genauso das erste woran ich
gedacht habe
und die werden jetzt machen mit einem
richtig einfach erzählt ich hoffe sie
werden auch gut schmecken letzt wird
pasteten sind hier immer so gefüllte
tank dinger eigentlich macht man den
teig selbst aber wir müssen jetzt
erstmal die flüssigkeit los werden von
den kleinen kunststückchen die dann
pürieren und da habe ich mir gedacht ein
bisschen abwechslung hatte noch ein
hocker ido brotaufstrich gemacht wenn
auch mit kanzlerin ich glaube das ist
tatsächlich mal besser kommt zum
abschnitten sehr gut 225 gramm
ich bewahre mir das andere mal auf
leicht wird hier drin trainieren wir das
ganze dann hält er denn sagen max maas
nicht direkt in diesem behälter gekommen
außerdem dazu müssen 5 und 5
durch gramm zucker wird ob jetzt jeweils
also durch fest ein achtel teelöffel
muskatnuss um 10.18 teelöffel da kann
man vielleicht gar nicht sein das ist ja
der acht dafür perfekt und jetzt das
gleiche nochmal mit muskatnuss das geben
wir jetzt auch noch dazu
täter würden erneut sagen wir dass das
nicht einfach da drin abgefunden dass
hier viel sein ist genau so geworden wie
ich mir vorgestellt habe
wir müssen jetzt so kleine runde hinaus
stoßen laut dem rezeptbuch macht man das
mit sondern und rap taste 1 esslöffel 12
sollen jetzt nehmen wir den teig
vorsichtig hier darüber sehr gut das hat
schon mal traten mit nadal an
wir müssen dann auch gleich noch die
dinger von oben anritzen soweit die
anderen rufen und das sind die dinge
sind also wie kleine spiegel
das sind die kirche darstellten kerle
ist jetzt auch offiziell arbeiten wir
noch einmal an glaube das reicht
wahrscheinlich schon okay wollte die
zeit ist um
sind schon mehr so dass ich höre jetzt
mal raus und dann sehen es vielleicht um
grad kommt die anderen hoch
das sind kürbis pasteten von harry
potter kommt rein okay ich bin mit allen
testkandidaten jetzt hier
ich habe mich extra eintritt von der
pullover angezogen und wir werden jetzt
die kürbis pasteten aus harry potter
testen kelly du bist most
harry-potter-fan da es dem titel krieg
zuerst einfach mal neben dir probiert
ich konnte mir nicht vorstellen so schön
lecker von spezieller prozess gewürzt
und kürzt das nicht immer das schmeckt
wirklich gut gegessen
jetzt weiß ich warum harry
innenverteidigung ist und so wenn du das
ist ein paar zeitungen
ich wollte man allergisch dagegen
und jetzt schauen wir haben es jetzt ins
wohnzimmer gechillt der films schon
bereit und ich habe jede menge mobil
snackt wir uns gekauft aber falls ihr
dachtet das wäre alles okay
deswegen sind dann mal bist du okay gibt
man den teile hat so könnte man anders
sein
das schmeckt sowie gemeinheit wirtschaft
wir meinen dass vortrag nach
karamellisiertem butter geil oder ein
gott wie weder das ich kenne das schon
und habe somit kann ich zusammen war
schon immer probieren
[Musik]
hallo jetzt passiert was richtiges wir
gucken die extended version und die
dauert drei stunden und deshalb ist die
konzentration ein bisschen abnehmen
ok macht's gut freunde wenn wir sehen
uns in den hunderten sind kaputt war
okay leute ich bin jetzt auch wirklich
richtig müde aber was für ein tag
es hat mir so viel spaß gemacht dieses
video zu drehen einfach ein tag im harry
potter universum zu leben deshalb noch
mal dick ist ein schon an google und
animation eid für diese leiste
gelegenheit die neueste kampagne und oh
mein gott macht euch erstmal auf den
trip in die usa gefasst wird komplett
crazy ich freue mich darauf bald geht es
für mich los wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten video wieder mach's gut und bis
dahin tschüss
[Musik]